oh hé tu es dans le dortoir de la planète ouais j'ai
plié ton pantalon pour toi super
peut-être que ce sera éteint peut-être que tu devrais
changer l'eau la prochaine fois super utile
ne sois pas en retard à ta fête ce soir d'accord au
revoir
voir joyeux anniversaire je dois feuilleter un livre  maman
j'ai un pick and roll
me voici
vécu cette journée pour que vous puissiez entendre maintenant,
tout va bien en
supposant que je crois que tout cela est
même possible Frank alarme de voiture bizarre la
façon dont je vous ai demandé que vous avez un
nombre illimité de vies des possibilités illimitées
de bombarder son propre meurtre quelqu'un
censé continuer à mourir jusqu'à  Je
découvre qui est mon assassin tu veux vivre
avec toi demain,
celui qui te tue sait que c'est ton
anniversaire à
peu près toute la scolarité en ces
temps de grande promesse, il est sûr que tu as
réalisé le même jour encore et encore
et nous voyons  êtes vraiment
[Applaudissements]
vous